foreign
video games non-stop so I started
setting boundaries with him
and he decided that he would rather be
divorced than
live with me anymore
[Music]
this is John with the Dr John deloney
show
so grateful that you've joined us
show about your mental health your
emotional health your marriage your kids
your who you're trying to date losing a
loved one all of it whatever is going on
in your life that's what we talked about
on this show real people going through
real challenges if you want to be on the
show give me a buzz
1-844-693-3291 it's
1-844-693-3291 or go to John deloney.com
ask a-s-k and don't forget we are in
pre-sale for my new book building a
non-anxious life
the way we have approached mental health
in this country over the last hundred
years is simply not working and I know
that's a bold statement and I know it's
a hard statement for me to make because
that's my community that's I I've spent
my life dedicated my life to helping
people and we've got to do something
different just look around right just
look around so this book is about the
choices we can make to create a
non-anxious non-burned out not non uh
chronically stressed life and I promise
you
whoever you are there are choices that
you can make go to John deloney.com to
pre-order the book it's 20 bucks it
comes with a jillion
um cool pre-sale items that we will roll
out to you over the next few weeks in a
few months but get after it John
deloney.com building a non-anxious life
pretty hyped all right let's go out to
Las Cruces New Mexico I know where Las
Cruces is what's up Bridget
hello how we doing
um I'm okay excellent how long you've
been in lost well I won't even ask that
question let's just go right to the call
what's up how can I help
um I'm trying to figure out how I can
stop being a people pleaser
you called the wrong guy because I have
a problem with that too I struggle with
that
um tell me how how that works in your
life
um well I was married for 13 and a half
years
and
um
the whole time I was
people pleasing I wouldn't
like I would just give in I wouldn't
even say what I wanted or what I needed
and so it got to the point where my
husband
um
started to make jokes about making me
his sugar mama
and
then he went and quit his job and
proceeded to play video games Non-Stop
and
so I started setting boundaries with him
and he decided that he would rather be
divorced than live with me anymore and
and then he immediately
asked me if he could start dating before
we were divorced
and I told him no but he did it anyway
and then he talked me into
giving him written permission to
continue dating his girlfriend because
she was gonna
break up with him
um
if I didn't give him permission and so I
did
and then within two weeks of our divorce
being final he started
trying to talk me into letting her meet
the kids
and I felt like it was too soon
and then
he got her a ticket to come see us and
meet the kids and
without talking to me about it first and
so I told him that we wouldn't we
wouldn't be meeting with them I have
full custody
and legal decision making and so I don't
have to let him see him if I don't feel
like what he's going to do is right
but he started talking about taking me
back to court to
um
to get more rights and I felt like that
would hurt my kids more than meeting the
girlfriend
and but then he started
he also started yelling at me that he
gave me everything in the divorce but
that wasn't what I wanted
I wanted him to work with me on what he
should take
because I feel like he's going to hold
it over my head for the rest of my life
and Bridget what I don't yeah
so I don't I don't know that you're a
people pleaser you sound like somebody
who's been very wise about trying to
keep herself and her kids safe
and you're married to a manipulative
absolute jerk
who has been a selfish child and has
treated you like crap
and there's you're like well well played
well played
um I I
these kind of calls break my heart
Bridget because
there's you just laid out a pattern of
how this guy has completely crapped on
you and your kids
and the dreams you had in your life
together
and
you are probably from stimming all the
way back from me when you were a little
girl and you were made responsible for
the way mom got mad or if Dad got pissed
off it was probably Bridget's fault
Bridget you shouldn't done that now your
dad's old man
and now somebody just ran over you with
a car and you're wondering what you did
wrong
the only thing I would recommend that
you can do differently from this point
forward is to cut this guy out of your
life block him
you have a hundred percent custody
you have no reason to talk to him
the judge in New Mexico thought he was
so not good for your kids that they said
it's better for kids to not see him
then to come up with some sort of
custody arrangement
and you and I both know that judges
rarely do that unless there is some
really gnarly stuff going on
well I think mostly is because he didn't
fight me on anything like he was the one
that wanted the divorce
but I was the one that had to file
I know because he's a coward and you
know what he did he went to his new
girlfriend and said my wife divorced me
that's the way he can tell that story to
everybody
he didn't even have the courage
to go through with what he did he moved
out on you and made you deal with the
legal paperwork
I don't think he did anything wrong here
I think you kept I think you kept
yourself safe
what I want you to do now is realize the
position of strength you are in
and you are not beholden to this guy
anymore
and I'll tell you as a dad and a husband
let's just say my wife chose to leave me
or I chose to leave my wife
and we ended up going through the
divorce process and she filed for a
hundred percent custody
Bridget that ain't happening on my watch
I'll spend every dime I have because I
can't breathe without my kids around
even when they're driving me crazy
I can't breathe without my kids
and I can't breathe without my wife for
that matter so this whole the whole
scenario is kind of kind of fictitious
but let me just say
even when husbands leave their wives
they don't cash out on their kids too it
just paints a picture of who this guy is
and he is not worthy of having you in
his life anymore he left you
and if he wants to take you back to
court knock his lights out
and if the judge
changes their original finding
and demands that he sees part then
you'll live in that world
where they'll get to see their dad some
of the time
but I don't want you here's where the
people pleaser comes in no no you'll be
you won't be people pleasing you'll be
doing what the judge said
you'll be fine like
I don't know if I have the strength to
what to make that fight to fight
I didn't see the kids like I I don't
want them to live with their dad in
their life you're uh you're imagining a
fight that hasn't even happened yet and
you're making actions in the present
tense on something that probably won't
happen in the future
if he is so much of a coward that he
wouldn't even file on you and he asked
for a permission slip for him to hook up
with somebody else we all were still
married you realize how ridiculous that
is
yes that's I mean again
it's rare that I've never heard of
something I've never heard of a written
permission slip
I mean that's insane it's obnoxious
the chances of this dude getting a
lawyer and fighting you are very small
and if he does he's gonna do it anyway
right what I want Bridget to understand
is you're in the driver's seat now and
it's a scary thing to be driving
and you're going to need some women in
your life that will Coach you and walk
alongside you
and hold your arms up in the desert when
they get tired
because it's a long slog and Las Cruces
is an unforgiving place I've been there
a lot
Eastern New Mexico is tough right
yes stuff
and so maybe you ask yourself is this
where I want to stay is this my forever
place what kind of Life do I want to
build for me now
well that's also another thing is that
he hated it here so badly
but that's if that's his excuse for
getting up the kids and not fighting
that because he couldn't live here
so he moved away and now he's trying to
talk me into moving and I'm like I think
you just solidified my plan to die here
well done Bridget
well done or or this is just plot twist
here there's a whole other country you
can move to moving doesn't mean you have
to go with him
you can go anywhere oh well he he
basically wants me to move just anywhere
he doesn't get a vote he left you
stop giving
four boxes of farts with this dude once
listen you should not know who he's
dating
he left you you shouldn't know what her
name is where she lives and he shouldn't
know how to contact you
and at some point you may need to sell
your house and move
and put your new place under a trust so
he has no idea where you are
he left you yeah yeah she can
well I have to let him know when I move
I was in the legal paperwork all right
why would you need to let him know you
have a hundred percent custody
well I mean
basically what it says in the paperwork
is that they are with me 100 of the time
unless we decided in writing together
that they're going to be with him okay
that's fair so that basically said he
was I basically said yeah uncontested
dad was such a loser he didn't even he
doesn't want to go
yeah Dad was such a loser he wouldn't
even show up to say I would like to see
my kid so the judge was like well crap
then you can't see him unless you one
day put on big boy pants and you decide
to be a father
and then mom's gonna have to say that's
cool
yeah
here's the thing you're in a position of
strength
maybe for the first time in your life
and you're you're in a very vulnerable
scary position because you're a single
mom in Eastern New Mexico and that's
tough
both and
so you're gonna have to submit and get
some people in your life that you trust
that can walk alongside you
and
you're going to have to consider career
opportunities
I'm gonna hook you up with some stuff
for that
and you're gonna have to consider
choosing to change the way you interact
with the world are you in on that
because I really really what's the other
choice to go back with this with this
man child
no and have him sign more permission
slips
[Laughter]
can I go to the zoo and can I hook up
with somebody else so ridiculous
foreign
I want you to I I've got a
um close mentor of mine a remarkable
counselor therapist who lives in that
Community
um I want you to hang on the line and
off air I'm going to give that that name
to you okay I want you to reach out and
tell him I sent you okay I'm not gonna
put that name on the show because I
don't want him to get blown up but I'm
gonna um send that to you and I'm gonna
send you
um a couple of different things if
you're all in are you all in
yes
I'm gonna send you a bunch of stuff but
listen if I send you all this stuff and
I pay for it
and you go crawling back to man child
and say once you put down your video
game controller will you hug me and
he'll be like I don't know let me check
my permission slip and see when Susie's
coming over if you go back
come on you can't do that okay
all right if you're in you're in all
right here's what I'm gonna send you um
I'm gonna send you my friend Ken
Coleman's get clear assessment it's
about it's a it's an assessment you're
gonna take online it's going to take you
15 or 20 minutes I'm gonna send you a
free code and it is going to help
provide some direction for
what is some work or career
opportunities beyond what I'm doing now
that might a be more fulfilling and B
make me a whole bunch more money so I
can take care of my family
number two I'm going to send you his
book called The Proximity principle
which is just about man reaching out and
finding connections where you happen to
be
the third thing I'm going to send you is
my first big book own your past change
your future about how do you deal out of
Ash when somebody leaves you when the
worst things have happened how do you
deal with your childhood stuff and then
move on to be a functioning adult and
I'm going to send you my brand new book
building a non-anxious life
the things you can do every day every
week every every month to create a
non-chaotic non-stressful world okay are
you in I'm in how about this I'm gonna
send you something else I'm gonna send
you my buddy Dave Ramsey's Financial
Peace University course to help you get
your money straightened up
I know the data on single moms and it's
scary right
well probably not scary for you because
you've been dealing you just lost a big
kid that ate a bunch of your food bunch
of Cheetos down in the basement when
he's playing video games so maybe your
money may even be better I'm going to
send you Financial Peace but you got to
watch all the lessons and go through the
courses are you are you in
yes absolutely all right I'm gonna send
you all this stuff listen
gotta get some women in your life some
real life people and you got to give my
buddy a call okay and I'll tell you his
name off here
um I'm so grateful that you called I
don't think you're a people pleaser I
think you're somebody who has learned
over time to keep yourself safe
and I think you get some people in your
life and you begin to create safety
choose safety and that might mean not
responding to text messages that might
mean
um blocking people from your phone
that might mean doing all sorts of
things to create boundaries to keep you
safe
choosing Freedom you're not dragging me
around anymore I'm unhooking myself from
the back of your truck and I'm gonna
start walking a moon two feet scary but
I promise you you've got the strength to
do it
and when you don't have the the strength
in those in those rare moments when
things get heavy that's what your
community is going to be for that's what
your counselor is going to be for
that's what your pastor is going to be
for it's gonna be reaching out to
support people you can call this show
anytime and we'll put you through
Bridget I'm here to walk with you
I know it's a mess
you got this and we got it with you
and on the line we'll be right back
this show is sponsored by better help
hey folks all of us need a little
guidance sometimes in life we're faced
with tough situations and choices and
the way forward isn't always clear I've
been in that position in fact I'm in
that position right now and therapy is
helping me find a path through it
whether it's a career decision
relationship at a Crossroads or some
other struggle you're facing you need
someone to talk with to move ahead with
confidence so if you've ever considered
therapy I recommend better help better
help connect you with a licensed
therapist who can walk with you on that
journey to discover who you want to
become betterhelp is entirely online so
it's convenient flexible and it fits
your schedule whatever your schedule may
be just fill out a brief questionnaire
to get matched with a licensed therapist
and you can switch therapists at any
time for no additional charge
so let therapy be your map with better
help visit betterhelp.com deloney today
to get 10 off your first month that's a
better help
h-e-l-p.com slash deloni
all right let's go out to Salt Lake City
Utah and talk to the great and wonderful
Jeremy what's up Jeremy what's up John
it's great to talk to you and also with
you how we doing man
well I'm doing all right uh a little
nervous talking to you in real life
don't be nervous man uh how can I help
brother what's up
okay so I'm gonna start with my question
um
so
well the other day I kind of had to turn
on the lights
and just kind of see where my life was
at and I realized that I was utterly
alone in spirit and in mind and I try
getting on the dating scene and doing
dating and it just
it doesn't work out either on their end
or my end and I'm just trying to find
ways that I can love myself to where
I can be there and
um
and
uh
be a part of the dating scene yeah I
don't I don't know how to best explain
it again I get it what what happened
usually those moments when we take an
inventory of our life as you said we
just turn the lights on
usually there's there's a thing that
happens
correct so I was sitting around and I
just I was feeling really just bummed
out and I just decided to I was just
like why why am I so sad about
like the day going on and
and uh
I I had kind of uh I just don't like how
I'm feeling right now and then I had uh
I started having kind of a panic attack
and
after I was able to calm that down I was
able to take inventory and I'm just
I just realized that I'm just all alone
and you know I have I have community
but
I don't why why do you feel like you
can't tell that Community who you really
are
I don't know I've I've just I just
learned recently how to be vulnerable
because of your show to my own family
it's awesome yeah but sometimes
sometimes family is a double-edged sword
they're great and they also can be the
source of some of our challenges
especially from childhood even though
they didn't mean to and so
it's kind of sometimes it's going back
to the rattlesnake and saying hey
um just wanted you to know like I'm
recovering from how I used to bite me
all the time
and you have to put yourself back in
distance of getting bit by the same
rattlesnake again correct and
unfortunately
um a score of seven on the aces
and
um just recently I decided that after
listening to your show that I wasn't
going to be responsible for my parents
parents's emotion and I decided to
yeah it was a hard one and so I decided
to have a deep conversation with with my
mom you know she's still around and
that was hard and you know she took it
quite well but
this this is all just from
and
I kind of noticed that I was having kind
of like
um
like uh
wanting to check out
but I'm not I'm not a danger to myself
but
I'm
I just keep I just keep thinking man if
this doesn't get any better
like what is it gonna be like what am I
gonna do
and so I got to the point that I was
like I I need to throw a hell of Mary
now yeah
so let me tell you let me tell you
brother you're you're way way you think
this is the fourth quarter you're not
even done the first half yet
you know you're you don't need to be
thrown Hill married yet
you had a game plan or you had a coach
with a game plan and that got your head
knocked off in the first quarter and
then you're like dude I'm not playing
for this coach anymore
and courageously like very very few
people
you sat down with the rattlesnake and
you said you're not biting me anymore
I think dude that's incredible
what we don't do enough and I'll own
some of this man what I don't do enough
is let people know that when you do put
up a boundary
there is a feeling of silence and
isolation behind that boundary for a
minute
because it's new
it's scary because you're all by
yourself
yeah so it feels
you're not crazy and you're not broken
your body's actually going whoa where is
everybody
and
um you've heard me say on the shows your
body will will solve for equilibrium
you'll try to get back upsell for
homeostasis I'm sorry it'll try to get
back to the way it was it will go find
another dysfunctional relationship where
somebody drags you around and makes you
responsible which is why you're probably
dating people that are so familiar and
fun and then really quickly they remind
you a lot of the crap you went through
as a kid
and then you're like I'm out of here and
then it just starts over again
because your body wants to solve for
what it knows even if what it knows is
killing you
or I'll find a reason why I shouldn't be
with them and
you know why that is right you've heard
me talk about that
is because of insecurity no no that's
you trying to beat yourself up when you
say about insecurity it's because your
body put a GPS pin and getting too close
to somebody because the last time you
did that I got you got you hurt bad
yeah and it probably came from Mom and
Dad
and or a big chunk of it did or Mom and
Dad were stood by and let it happen or
they didn't show up when it did happen
all that stuff and so your body knows
hey those two aren't going to step in
nobody's gonna step in
and so once we cross a threshold to get
too close I'm sounding every alarm I got
because I gotta I gotta protect you
because you're you Jeremy are too
interested in hooking up with somebody
and connecting with somebody and getting
some long-term stability and I got to
Keep Us Alive so your brain sounds the
alarms you break up you move on or you
do something that's erratic or not you
you text somebody 400 times in one night
because you feel anxious about the way
y'all left right fair right fair and
then they were like whoa too much and
they break up with you and then you
self-sabot the whole thing right so yeah
for sure it's a matter of okay we put up
some boundaries
well the good news is me and my mom have
a great relationship it's awesome I love
her absolutely so it wasn't terrible but
I was
I was just always afraid to have that
conversation with her
absolutely absolutely
so
really what I want you to think of the
Season you're in
is
um
you just got picked up on a basketball
team and they saw how good you were as
an athlete you just don't know anything
about basketball
and they put you out on the court and
you can run and you can jump and you can
rebound every once in a while but your
shots look ridiculous
when you shoot you're not even close to
The Who
and when they're like
go go play the four go play the four
down the block you're like I don't know
what that means right I don't have the
idea or they're like yeah just run a
simple motion and you're like I don't
know what that is
all it is is it has nothing to do with
your ability has nothing to do with your
um brains it has nothing to do with your
um
athletic prowess
you just gotta learn some new skills
that's it
and so it's going to be awkward it's
going to be uncomfortable but it's going
to be going towards the right thing
yeah see what I'm saying yeah now here's
what I'm going to challenge you on
I think you probably think and feel and
have lots of emotions
and in many ways those thoughts and
feelings and heavy emotions become
paralyzing
and I want you to come up with
a note card worth of
things you will commit to doing on a
daily basis
I don't care how you feel I don't care
what you think I don't care what your
emotions feel like I don't care if your
feet feel like lead
I will do these things
yeah and you're gonna have to act your
way into becoming
a person you are proud of
I'm proud as hell of you right now but
the what I feel about you doesn't matter
you've been chasing external validation
your whole life and you've realized at
this point it doesn't fill you up
doesn't work
and it's also in some parts hard to
believe that's right you know
because you know
that you didn't even exercise today
you know that you had some work
assignments I didn't even do them today
you know
yeah and so the way I've heard it said
that I love is if you're looking for
somebody when someone says like Hey how
do I find somebody to date and connect
with
it sounds counterintuitive but I want
you to be calm to focus on you with an
intensity of becoming the best version
of you
I'm gonna exercise I'm gonna sign up for
a local community college class to take
a course in Shakespeare or psychology or
theater I'm going to do something so out
of my wheelhouse but I'm going to go
every class
yeah I'm gonna learn how to dance
and I've been to Salt Lake you all
cannot dance
right I I I'm gonna do these things
I'm gonna learn Spanish I am going to
learn wood cutting I'm gonna do stuff
that I want to do that I love doing and
my promise to you Jeremy is as you grow
in
micro achievements little bitty like I
don't know how to play this song on
guitar and I'm gonna sit there and sit
there and sit there until I figure it
out and I'm going to be able to play it
and I will walk two inches taller to go
to bed that night let me get up tomorrow
and do it again
yeah you spend so much time thinking and
thinking and thinking and thinking and
feeling and feeling and feeling and
thinking
and I want to give your body some like a
season of little wins
I'm gonna call a friend I'm gonna call a
friend I'm gonna call a friend and then
I'm not gonna text him when we get done
I'm gonna feel how awkward in that
little spinny I shouldn't have said this
I hope you think it's funny
I have a buddy of mine I do have a buddy
of mine who I love
who we hang out and we hang out for a
while and then sends me long texts like
so sorry dude I was weird a little bit
awkward today and finally I called and I
was like you're never allowed to post
hangout text me ever again
like you're my friend of course you're
weird and you're my friend of course you
say dumb things I do too you're my
friend
you don't need to you're not you're not
at a job interview
you're my friend yeah right
you have to practice that
do you have three friends that you could
call right now
and invite him over for dinner this week
and say hey I've never told you guys
about my childhood and I talked to this
goofball on YouTube or on podcast
and he kept telling me that grief
Demands a witness so I just want to tell
you about some stuff that happened and I
know it's gonna be weird but
I trust y'all
do you have three people you could do
that with oh that's so hard because bro
I know I know
that's the I I'm hope I'm an open book
it's just no you're not you are not you
have you have uh ripped out chapters one
through five out of your story I'm an
open book until you get to The First
beginning that's right you don't let
anybody read chapters one through five
you want them to just pick you up after
you graduated college and look how fancy
I am
yeah and that's not your story man
okay your story is look at the hell I
endured and look who I've become on the
backside of this
yeah for sure that's your story
and the more you run from it
the the stronger it becomes
and when you're when you have friends
that You're vulnerable with when you
have
um somebody that you are dating and
you're and you're getting closer and
closer and closer to
they feel the secrets on you they just
don't know what it is and they think
it's their fault and it feels
uncomfortable and so it's easier to not
be in a relationship with those Secrets
I feel it right it's like being in a
dark room and you know there's like
someone's gonna jump out and grab you
you just don't know where it is you know
I'm getting out of here yeah it's that
yeah
and listen those three people
they could they could roast you with
your secrets no question
but they probably won't
or maybe get a counselor in practice
that's what I did I did it recently told
some hard hard stuff I had told zero
people
zero people
and then practicing with a counselor was
hard and healing
and then I told my wife and then I told
some friends
and it has a completely lost its power
over me
and see I wanted to go to counseling but
part of me allowed part of their
inside of me is just screaming what's
the point
you know let me tell you the point
how old are you brother
36 okay
I've got some years on you okay I'm in
my 40s now I'm an old man
I'll tell you the point
I laugh from my guts now
and I fall I fall asleep without meds
and I don't hardly ever drink anymore
because I don't need it to be close to
people
and
I have two knucklehead little kids that
I love more than life itself
and I have a wife that has been through
thick and thin and hell and back with me
and
um I just breathe easier when she's
around
oh that'd be that'd be a huge relief I
know but listen I only got there when I
started being honest
and I'm not talking about dishonest like
I'm not cheating on you and not not
that's not what I mean
I mean when I started saying things like
hey I really want this or I need this
I'm scared about this
and she finally said oh sweet man now I
can now I can connect
but I had to go first
yeah
it seems like a
climbing up a mountain it I can't
describe how perfect you're now you just
nailed it
there's a book by one of the most
extraordinary minds of Our Generation
his name is David Brooks and the book is
called the second Mountain I want you to
check that book out it's really really
powerful
um in fact it's real real powerful I
think you would I think you would really
benefit from it and hang on the line I'm
going to send you a copy of my brand new
book building a non-anxious life
and it's gonna it it is six choices and
it's a wheel
and if any one of these these choices
gets out of whack the the whole wheel
wobbles and the car won't drive the
right way the bike won't wobble will
fall off right so hang on the line I'm
gonna send you a copy of this thing I
want you to go through it start to
finish
square one all the way through
actually you know what I want you to um
pick up on your past change your future
too I know you've got a history with
Aces score and it talks about the aces
in in that book too helping you walk
through some of these challenges but
listen
you are not at Hail Mary time
am I a 100 expectation is if you wake up
and you say I'm ready to check out I'm
ready to not be alive anymore that you
will call somebody
I've got your word on that
but we're way way off from that
right now you're a young man he's 36
years old you're not even at the second
half yet
and yeah you got banged up in the first
quarter first half you did you got beat
up pretty good
you're gonna go in the locker room and
regroup get some people around you
change the game plan get some new
strategies change up the Personnel get a
new coach or two or three
and then we're gonna go back out there
and you said what's it all for let me
tell you why I got two little kids that
need you
because you my brother are creating the
world that they're gonna live in
I need you they need you your neighbors
need you
that woman that you're going to meet and
fall deeply in love with will need you
those little knucklehead kids that
you're gonna have one day will need you
[Music]
hang on the line brother I'm gonna send
you some stuff and get you hooked up
you call anytime
and I'll walk with you
thank you so much for being brave man
you you're the real deal Holyfield
Jeremy
you got a long road to go but man
that light's bright on the other side
we'll be right back
hey deloney here all right it's time to
declutter you got a treadmill covered in
dust you got magazines from five years
ago piled up in the corner a garage you
can't even Park in and all that clutter
and mess can lead to anxiety to just
feeling burned out and overwhelmed when
you hang on to the wrong things for too
long it can lead to something else bad
sleep that's right you might have the
same nasty lumpy mattress you've had for
decades just sitting up there gross your
sleep is way too important for that and
you're way too important one of the
easiest things you can do to improve
your physical and mental health is
invest in refreshing sleep and that
includes having a great new mattress
like a dream cloud and right now dream
cloud is making it a no-brainer to
upgrade your mattress with an offer just
for our listeners 40 off of all
mattresses plus an additional fifty
dollars in savings
it's time to start prioritizing your
sleep
clear out all the Clutter
get rid of that old mattress and go to
dreamcloudsleep.com and enter promo code
John deloney
that's dreamcloudsleep.com with code
Toronto and talk to Haley with a Y
what's up Haley
hello how we doing
good
um how are you so good I'm good what's
up
um I'm basically calling just because
um me and my family we've recently uh
kind of
um we went
through a one year anniversary of our
house burning down
yeah it happened July 3rd
um
2022 at 12 50 in the morning we all
inside
um
pardon were you all inside
yeah we were all
um asleep I was still up I was watching
YouTube
um when it all went down and so
for the better part of last year and
this year it was kind of like an
abandoned house
that still smelt like the smoke it did
that night and for the better part of um
uh last year we were just kind of like
watching it like be the same way that it
did that night and how we left it
um so now
in April they started April this year
they started to rebuild it and so now
I'm just kind of going through the
changes of like how symbolically it's
kind of making me grow up to see
um you know walls being taken down and
all the beautiful woodwork that we had
growing up being you know taken is this
a childhood home
yeah
so the only home I've known
so you had your childhood home and then
did you do you have your own family or
is this with your parents
my parents okay
how old are you
I'm 24. okay so your whole family lived
there
and then it burned down so now they're
having to go back and change it
yeah
I'm so sorry
so when they rebuild it are you all just
like in a temporary housing like in a
rental house or something
yeah we're we're in a rental about a
block away okay oh so you get to see it
every day right
yeah
um which is both good and harrowing
um
before I just start running my mouth how
can I help you directly
I guess I'm just trying to
notice and everything because for me
right now it's just basically me like
talking to my family or my friends about
it
and the weird part about talking about
it with your friends and stuff is that
they'll like look at you kind of pitiful
and you know and then telling people uh
that your house burned down as all boys
like kind of like in awkward situation
so
kind of like
meaning help navigating that are you
gonna move back in with them or are you
24 you're gonna go get your own place
now
says but I'm saving up to move out
hopefully next year
okay
um I guess there's a couple of things
here one is
one is dealing with the obvious events
of that night how scary it was going
door to door banging on doors and that
might mean sitting down with a counselor
and doing a couple of sessions of EMDR
just to process let that let the trauma
of that night circulate through your
body and be done be out okay okay
um you don't have to do that
um some people can do that journaling
some people can do that with exercise
and it's about letting that
letting that event run its course
I love the definition of trauma and
you're still within a year so you're
still there but I love the definition of
trauma is not what happened
it's our body's response to what
happened in the past in the present and
it's that memory that overrides our
ability to handle it in just every alarm
system we got starts ringing off the
wall
right and some people take traumatic
moments and tell everybody about them as
a way to try to control what happened
and you become a weird oversharer right
yeah you're like hey I'm Haley my house
burned down everyone's like whoa like
yeah new one notch right that's totally
normal it happens
and there's people who take what
happened and just put it in a lock box
and drop it in the ocean and hope they
never think or talk about it again
that's not good either right
um because people can feel those secrets
on you and they just don't know what to
do because they know they're not getting
the full you but they don't know where
the secrets are buried I don't even know
what's in those Secrets right
and so
there is a process by which you say to
yourself I wasn't safe then
but I am safe now
I wasn't okay then I almost lost my
family in a fire but we all got out we
made it
and I had an exercise where
um my granddad who passed away a few
years ago because 94 is a World War II
veteran he was just an awesome man one
of the greatest guys
he gave me when he found out I was
working in in higher education when I
was a professor and he gave me a
um Tweed coat like a like a suit jacket
that he had with the patches on the on
the elbows and everything it just looked
like a professor jacket out of a movie
and it never fit
I'm just I was just a bigger guy than
him but I always kept it because my
granddad gave it to him and this is just
about a year ago I was going through
like I do on a somewhat regular basis
getting rid of clothes just kind of
accumulator on the house and I saw the
jacket and I smiled like I always do and
I remember him and I moved it over into
the keep pile
and then I picked it back up
and I held it in front of me and I'll
never forget this moment I said to
myself
my granddad is not in this jacket
and then I put my hand on my chest I
made a fist and I said he's right here
and so I put the jacket in the Donate
pile and hopefully somebody who really
needed a nice jacket is wearing it now
because my granddad wasn't there
right so what I would tell you is your
memories your family they're not in that
woodworking
they're not there
a lot of cool stuff happened there and
we're gonna mourn the loss of that place
we're gonna grieve that place and I'll
tell you a couple things you can do to
facilitate that but
I want you to constantly remember
when you get overwhelmed with feeling
about the loss of that house or you
drive by and they're taking the roof off
or they're digging up holes in the yard
just looks like it looks terrible
I want you to say out loud to yourself
my family's not in that house
and then put your hand on your chest and
say my family's right here
okay okay now I want you to have this is
going to sound crazy I want you to
propose this to your parents
I want you to have some sort of
miniature funeral for that house
I want you to write a letter to it I
want you to have and y'all can laugh
your way through this you can laugh cry
your way through this it can be a big
old dramatic moment every family is
different my family would probably start
dying laughing we'd all end up in tears
by the end
yeah but I want you to have some sort of
memorial service for what was and give
yourself your body a chance to put a
period at the end of that sentence
and as we always do at funerals we talk
about memories we talk about the good
stuff we talk about the bad stuff
remember when the stupid hot water
heater kept breaking remember when there
was always that weird leak in that weird
sound and whatever happened
and then the most important part of a
funeral
is here's what happens next
here's who we're going to become in this
new house or we want this new house to
feel like what do we want this new house
what Memories do we want to create in
this new place
yeah and we're going to be intentional
about saying those things out loud
okay okay and by the way not everybody
gets access to this story
your close friends yeah
ooh boyfriend ooh are you dating
somebody no okay good don't ever but if
you do maybe that person gets access but
the people at the store at the grocery
store your classmates in school your
workmates they don't get all those
details
no right if if they ask or there's a
relationship be like yeah we had a big
fire last year oh that was your house
yeah it was my house but we don't have
to just dig into all of it see what I'm
saying and you can start to build some
boundaries around not secrets we can
start building some boundaries around
not everybody gets 100 Access to Haley
right
that makes sense okay I do a lot at you
how does that sound
it does sound really good
we can have a mini funeral for the house
will you try a funeral and let me know
how it goes maybe even take a picture
and email it to Jenna or Kelly I would
love to see that we'll put it in the
we'll put it okay we'll put it on the
show that'd be great
but all right do you think your mom and
dad would play along
probably
they'll play they'll play along get some
bagpipes
yeah there you go
see if the
they'll play along
yeah you think so you have any other
family that was there I have to included
uh no just pets but
they're okay what are you gonna say
you're gonna have to include what
I'll have to include a couple of drinks
uh the Irish people that are working on
the show oh
are cheering for you right now way to go
um yeah Haley that I mean it's
terrifying and scary
and when you lose your home there's so
much Tethered to that that structure
and so it's unnerving when that
structure goes away
and that structure can go away by fire
that structure can go away when you move
that structure can go away when you get
evicted there's something powerful about
that structure and it takes some
intentionality to back up an a heal from
the actual Sirens blaring lights
flashing his mom out is Dad out or all
the pets out like that Fierce is real
it's terrifying your body it overwhelms
your body's senses
and then there's the conscious
intentional move towards
okay this is what was let's honor it
let's laugh about it let's cry about it
and then let's begin dreaming about what
comes next
we'll start looking into what's this new
house gonna feel like and look like and
how long am I going to live there
because I need to go get my own place
because I'm 25 like whatever whatever
life looks like there
let's be intentional about planning what
happens next and hopefully in short
order as you drive by your house being
rebuilt it's not an oh my gosh I can't
believe they're taking that down it's oh
this is going to be amazing because
they're going to build something new
it's going to be a testament to the past
but a projection into the future
there'll be sad days
but hopefully the great days will weigh
out outweigh the settings thanks for the
call Haley you're awesome we'll be right
back
hey what's up Dr John deloney here check
it out my new book building a
non-anxious life is now available for
pre-order here's the great news anxiety
is not the enemy we've been led to
believe I know this because I've walked
alongside countless folks over the last
two decades and I've struggled with this
too if you create a life of
intentionally living out the six daily
choices I've outlined in this book
you're gonna be able to better respond
to whatever life throws at you you're
going to learn the choices you can make
day by day to create a more peaceful
joyful less chronically stressed
non-anxious life plus when you pre-order
my book I want to give you something to
help you today that's why you'll
instantly get my newest talk smoke fire
and freedom that I gave to several
thousand folks a few months ago where I
break down the misunderstandings and
myths we believe about anxiety how to
reclaim your freedom and how to build a
non-anxious life so pre-order building a
non-interest life today for just 20
bucks at John deloney.com
all right we are back in Action hey uh
just a heads up bagpipes are Scottish
not Irish
it's not all the same place
just wanted you to know that leprechauns
Ireland bagpipe Scotland
different people different countries
listen
I'm embarrassed
but I was a World Geography teacher so
I'm also ashamed a little bit and you
should be yeah
America I failed you
not just America
like the British Isles
the whole UK I was gonna make a Scotland
uh
I'm not doing anything I'm gonna say
to my Scottish friends
is that what is that that's not it no
that's pirate totally different
oh boy all right as you wrap up today's
show and I've just lost
um all of our Irish listeners
oh boy is that how we get canceled
might be yeah that's not cultural
appropriation it's like
and my family's Ira anyway I don't even
know my own Heritage that's what makes
it embarrassing this the song of the day
is from the great Shawn Mendes the song
is called in my blood and it goes like
this
help me it's like the walls are caving
in sometimes I feel like giving up but I
just can't
it isn't in my blood laying on the
bathroom floor feeling nothing am
overwhelmed and insecure give me
something I could take to ease my mind
slowly just have a drink and you'll feel
better just take her home and you'll
feel better keep telling me does it get
better does it ever
sometimes it feels like the walls are
caving in sometimes I feel like giving
up no medicine is strong enough someone
help me I'm crawling in my skin
sometimes I feel like giving up but I
just can't it isn't in my blood listen
to me if you're listening
listen to me
don't ever give up
love you guys we'll see you soon
[Music]